welcome to the man of recaps this is
stranger things season three welcome
back to hawkins indiana it's summer in
the 1980s so where better for our group
to spend their time than the brand new
state-of-the-art star court mall
remember at the end of season 2 11 l
used your psychic powers to close the
gate permanently trapping the mind
flayer in the upside down so the world
is safe there's nothing to worry about
unless the soviet era russians have
secretly infiltrated hawkins and are
doing crazy science experiments to
reopen the portal with the door cracked
open the remnants of the mind flyer
trapped out here could reanimate but
don't worry i'm sure that's not
happening our kids have grown up into
young teenagers now and the hormones are
raging mike and eleven spend the whole
summer making out this infuriates her
grumpy adopted dad police chief jim
hopper who tries and fails to enforce
the house rule keep the door open three
inches lucas and max are also happily
dating and even dustin apparently has a
new girlfriend susie he met at
engineering camp in fact he's built an
epic homemade radio tower to stay in
touch with her but she doesn't answer
and definitely seems made up this just
leaves will who's not into girls yet and
has trouble wrangling his girl crazy
friends for some dungeons and dragons
our older teenagers nancy and jonathan
are still dating as well they've
graduated high school now and both got
internships at the hawkins post nancy
wants to be a real reporter but it's a
bit of a boys club they don't take her
seriously then there's the high school
heartthrob steve the hare harrington but
now that he's graduated he's not the
prom king he's just slinging ice cream
and scoops ahoy and has kind of lost his
touch something his band nerd co-worker
robin is all too happy to rub in his
face and even the adults have caught the
love bug hopper and joyce buyers have
always had some chemistry but horniest
of all is mike's mom mrs wheeler who has
the hots for the new lifeguard max's
older brother billy yes he is a sex icon
but remember he has some serious anger
issues he and mrs wheeler have a fun
flirtation going but tonight's the night
to take it to the next level oh is this
really happening but in the end she
can't go through with it it was a sexy
fantasy but she's not gonna cheat on her
husband but billy's on the way to the
motel when he runs into some car trouble
outside this abandoned factory and wow
something grabs him what's happening
here oh
meanwhile hopper goes to joyce for
advice on how to talk to teenagers and
she advises him to write a note
expressing his feelings talking about
feelings is not really his strong suit
though so he goes for the tried and true
method threaten your daughter's
boyfriend so the next day mike says i
can't hang out my nana is sick but elle
knows he's lying she goes to talk to max
and these two weren't previously close
but it's like hey you can't hang out
with your boyfriend all the time you
need some girlfriends so they go off for
an epic mall day but they run into the
boys there oh you're so busted by the
way remember elle has a funny way of
talking from being raised in a science
lab but spending time with real kids
she's getting better
i dump your ass so mike and dell have
their first breakup and jim hopper's
feeling good so good in fact he finally
asks joyce out on a real date but she
stands him up yet joyce has been having
trouble with magnets lately so she goes
to see the smartest person in town the
boy's science teacher mr clark he
explains for all the magnets and hawkins
to lose their magnetism it would have to
be a massive machine she suspects the
government might be doing secret
experiments at the hawkins lab again but
she and hopper check it out there's
nothing here except this arnold
schwarzenegger terminator looking guy
who beats hopper up for snooping around
so they're wrapped up in another
conspiracy meanwhile dustin while trying
to contact susie intercepts a russian
broadcast his friends are busy with girl
trouble so he goes to his new best
friend steve harrington yeah remember
these two bonded in season two they're
trying to translate the message to save
america from a red dawn invasion but
they're hopeless luckily robin has a
great ear for languages and pretty soon
figures it out unfortunately it's just a
nonsense code but robin continues to be
the mvp when she realizes it's all about
stuff in the mall that night they do
some snooping and soon it's apparent the
star court mall is a cover for a secret
russian base nancy and jonathan coming
in from another angle work in a weird
story about rabid rats that turns out
are possessed by the mind player
speaking of possessed billy is feeling
rather weird and soon finds himself
compelled to kidnap his co-worker and
bring her to the mind player's new rat
made body max and nell are playing a fun
sleepover game where they use el psychic
powers to spy on the boys but when it's
time to see what billy's up to oh he can
see her and something's really wrong
they check on billy but everything's
fine they're acting weirdly normal until
of course they attack this girl's
parents yes it's a classic invasion of
the body snatchers this gross fleshy
mind player has gotten real big and it's
possessing all of hawkins will byers is
having a breakdown lamenting the end of
his childhood but now he can't ignore it
anymore he's got to admit the mind
player's back so now the kids all
working together they're pretty sure
billy's possessed they make a plan to
lock him in the sauna cause the mind
player can't stand heat and if they're
wrong this is a really weird mean prank
but of course they're right and the mind
flare juices billy wow he's got super
strength he goes full darth vader on 11
but finally she's able to knock him out
of there then when nancy and jonathan
realize there's something very wrong
with rat lady they finally joined the
kids group too meanwhile the scoops ahoy
group is working on the maul russian
angle steve and dustin continue to be
funny but hopeless but there is someone
who would fit in those air vents it's
lucas's little sister erica you can't
spell america without erica she is a
hilariously precocious enterprising
young kid who agrees to help him out for
free ice cream for life she crawls
through the vents and opens the door no
problem but unfortunately this storage
room is actually an elevator and they're
going way down there now chief hopper
recognized that terminator coming out of
the scumbag mayor's office so he pays
him another visit and learns that the
russians have bribed him to buy a
property around hawkins at one of those
houses they find some russian scientists
but then it's the terminator fight round
two but they managed to grab one of the
scientists and get out of there after a
walk through the woods and a stop for
slurpees they commandeer this vehicle
from the tod father they go to the only
person hopper knows who speaks russian
it's murray bauman yeah remember he's
the reporter conspiracy theorist that
helped him in season 2. now the
scientist is alexi and he's happy to
talk in exchange for some fast food
there's immediately a problem though
because hopper got him a strawberry
slurpee when he asked for cherry this is
a grievous insult to any slurpee
enthusiast hopper though does not see
the difference meanwhile the scoops
group has managed to avoid detection and
finds themselves in a james bond style
secret russian facility complete with
portal to the upside down the older kids
buy time for dustin and erica to escape
but now robin and steve are captured for
their interrogation the russians bring
in the doctor who's got his homemade
truth serum but turns out that serum is
mostly lsd and has a real nice mellow
high the younger kids bust in to save
them and now have to chaperone these
tripping teenagers who just have a real
nice night together once it's wearing
off they have a heart to heart in the
bathroom where steve's like hey robin i
think i like you it's like steve i like
you too but i don't like you like you i
like girls so yeah these two do not get
a romance they get to be just bffs the
kids go to the hospital to check on rat
lady and lucas solidifies his status as
a ladies man by teaching mike how to win
l back give her candy but upstairs
things go bad for the teenagers when
their former newspaper bosses are now
possessed and have michael meyer's super
strength they managed to kill him but
now that their bodies are of no use the
mind player melts them down and all
gross what's this oh that big flesh
monster yeah nancy and jonathan have it
rough everyone else is having fun while
they're stuck in the horror genre but
now the kids join them and l beats this
thing with their psychic powers but that
was just one small piece of a much
bigger problem so ellen the kids try to
find the mind player source by going
into billy's mind el finds his good
memories from when he was a happy kid
who loved his mom but he's got a lot of
bad ones like his awful abusive father
and now you feel bad for poor billy
unfortunately the connection goes both
ways now the mind player knows where l
is it calls in its minions from all over
hawkins and melts them all down to make
a massive monster body it attacks
hopper's cabin where there's a massive
monster fight oh gonna get her shotgun
blast in the end 11 rips that thing
apart but eventually it'll just put
itself back together finally the game
gets in touch with dustin who
unfortunately is still trapped in the
mall but levin gets there just in time
to hit these guys with a car and now
both our young crews are together
siblings lucas and erica are surprised
to see each other and robin's surprised
to learn that 11 has psychic powers but
in any case they all bring each other up
to speed the adults finally are up to
speed too hopper calls in the cia when
joyce gives them the real mama bear
talking to cause their kids are in
danger on the drive back hopper and
joyce keep arguing so murray bauman the
love guru who got nancy and jonathan
together last season tells them to skip
the foreplay just pull over and get it
on which i mean they don't now the kids
are supposed to be at the 4th of july
fair so while hopper and joyce search
for him alexi has the best night of his
life he's about to try his first corndog
but the terminators tracked him down and
oh silent walk by assassination no alexi
was such a nice guy just loved slurpees
and cartoons but there's no saving him
alexi dies hoppers fighting russians in
the funhouse in the hall of mirrors he
gets the jump on terminator but he was
wearing a bulletproof vest but now on
their radio they hear about kids in the
mall eleven's having trouble with the
mind flare bite on her leg it left a
little piece of itself in there super
gross but now finally the adults arrive
and our entire party is united now that
everyone's up to speed the plan is for
the adults to take over go down and
close the portal but they need
directions from the kids who are down
there so this scoops troop sticks
together going off to dustin's big radio
to guide them over the walk the rest of
the kids are supposed to run away and
lay low but possessed billy's out there
waiting for him and unfortunately since
her leg injury elle's psychic powers are
not working so while hopper is earning
the nickname alexi gave him fat rambo
and murray is reluctantly forced to
accept his callsign bald eagle hopper
and joyce have a heart-to-heart where
she's like hey if we survive this i'll
take you up on that date but upstairs
the giant fleshy mind player has entered
the mall and our kids are hiding for
their lives half the group makes it out
but billy's not gonna let that happen
luckily boom steve harrington heard they
were in trouble and comes to save the
day they all hop in the station wagon
and are leading the monster away and now
we have another problem the code to the
safe is plank's constant apparently a
famous mathematical number without alexi
though no one here knows it but there is
one person who definitely knows it way
over in utah dustin's fake girlfriend
susie is real yeah dusty buns and suzy
poo reunited but she's pretty mad at him
for ignoring her for three days and now
randomly asking about plank's constant
she won't tell him what it is till he
apologizes and there's only one way to
do it with their wildly embarrassing
very personal couples thing
singing the theme song together of the
never ending story it is absolutely
adorable but it's made hilarious by all
the random people listening in some of
whom are in mortal peril finally susie
tells him the number so now they got the
shutdown keys and bust in there ready to
close the portal permanently but the
terminators here ready for round four
billy is also in terminator mode and he
brings l to the mind player so it can
possess her but just then boom fireworks
yes our crews all come back it's an epic
4th of july celebration just the way
george washington would have wanted it
meanwhile els trying to unpossess billy
by reminding him of his good memories
and it works a de-possessed billy now
stands up to his former master he's
ready to sacrifice himself to protect
these kids and unfortunately right at
the start of his potential redemption
arc no billy is killed it's especially
tragic for max the complexities and
depth of their brother-sister dynamic
were complex and deep meanwhile at the
portal things are not going great but
hopper manages to turn the tide and owl
throws this guy into the machine
unfortunately now it's malfunctioning
and has trapped hopper on the wrong side
to save their kids they can't wait so
it's another heartbreaking moment as
joyce has to sacrifice hopper by blowing
up this machine disintegrating everyone
in the area but the gate does close and
now cut off from its wifi signal the
fleshy mind flayer monster dies
now the cavalry rides in and the good
cia here to clean this mess up we
suffered tremendous losses but the day
is saved a little while later life is
getting somewhat back to normal with
them all destroyed steven robin get a
new job at the video rental store but
there's another massive change the
buyers family has been through too much
trauma in hawkins they're moving nancy
and jonathan say their goodbyes they're
going long distance which always works
out and turns out 11 is leaving too
she's going with the buyers i guess it
would be weird to be adopted by your
boyfriend's family so they're going long
distance too but have a big milestone
when they say i love you wow drop in l
bombs by the way eleven's powers have
not come back yet so watch out for that
but now get ready to cry when eleven
finds the old note hopper wrote for him
trying to express his feelings turns out
he actually wrote some beautiful stuff
about how eleven's his daughter and
brought meaning back to his life and the
heart-wrenching sign-off line just
please leave the door open three inches
so the group all says farewell for now
as the buyer's family leaves hawkins and
that's where stranger things season
three comes to an end but we're not done
yet there's an after the credit scene in
russia what are they doing at this
secret facility what's behind that gate
oh say it ain't so it's a classic season
one demogorgon but double weight we're
still not done yet spoilers ahead if
you're the type of person that doesn't
even watch a single trailer or anything
but at the secret russian facility
there's a bunch of prisoners building
railroad tracks and one of them is
shaved head chief jim hopper how did he
survive how did he get here find out in
stranger things season four
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]